hello and welcome to another thrilling
episode of the into the impossible
podcast featuring a renowned astronomer
barbara ryden who is a
teacher an educator a scientist an
astrophysicist and a professor at the
ohio state university
her research considers the formation
shape and structure of galaxies and
she's written numerous books but the
reason that i wanted to interview her is
that i've been teaching a cosmology
course for advanced undergraduates at uc
san diego since
2006. i can't believe it
my 16th year teaching this class and by
far the only book i've ever used despite
all the other options
is barbara's textbook and she's a little
bit unusual in that there aren't so many
uh textbooks written by women in
astronomy or in physics and so i think
and i claim and i don't think i was
refuted by barbara even that this was is
perhaps the most widely read book uh
written by a female physicist
astrophysicist in her case um that we
use as a textbook and i think uh that's
quite an accomplishment
it's not only you know because she's a
woman but because she's such a
phenomenal writer she's hilarious she is
mesmerizingly intellectual and she has
this
mercurial delightful way of of looking
at the universe which i try to convey to
my students and they love her book and
they love her work
and i just thought it would be a treat
so i reached out to her on facebook and
um and she responded and now here she is
on the show now this was recorded right
after the end of semester uh of spring
semester 2021
and so it's taken me a while to get
through to process all the other
episodes in the queue but now that i
have it's such a delight to review it
and to re-encounter it so i think it's
really amazing to think about how much
she's accomplished and
um and what her career has led to i'll
just give a short list of her uh of her
of her accomplishments her honoraria and
so forth
she studied physics at northwestern she
went to princeton or she was a phd
student for
working with dr james gunn
is a renowned scientist recent recipient
of the kyoto prize here in san diego by
the way
she was a research fellow at harvard's
center for astrophysics and also at ceta
the canadian institute for theoretical
astrophysics she's been at ohio state
since 1992 looking at sloan digital sky
survey which she and jim gunn and others
helped to pioneer uh she won the 1994
national science foundation young
investigators awards most prestigious
award for young faculty that the nsf
gives out she won the chambliss
astronomy writing award she's elected
fellow of the american association for
the advancement of science as well
uh in 2016.
and uh like you'll hear she's just a
delight to talk to to learn from and i
find it uh just overwhelmingly
gratifying that such intellects will
grace me by coming on uh coming on the
podcast so for now i want you to sit
back
relax and come along into the impossible
with professor
barbara
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
open the pod bay doors now
get started today we're going to kick
off this conversation with one of my
heroes my favorite authors this is
barbara ryden professor ohio state
university
joining us all the way from the great
state a great buck i state she is an
american astrophysicist a fellow of the
american association for the advancement
of science a renowned teacher and
educator
and worked with copley prize winner last
year
jim gunn who won the kavli prize and i
was honored to kind of present
his award or help present his award at
the kavli ceremonies that were delayed
and then postponed and then regurgitated
but anyway barbara how are you doing
today how's your cat
i'm doing fine my cat misses chippy
hello of course we have to highlight mrs
chippy here wow
comes and jumps on my lap whenever she
hears me talking to the laptop so cats
are useful to cosmologists as well as to
quantum physicists but no cats will be
harmed during the filming of this
episode uh barbara you're one of my
favorite authors and your book perhaps
is the book that i've bought the most
with my hard-earned money
as a state university employee more than
any other person i'm keeping keeping
your cat in
in charm school
i want to thank you for the books and
everything you've done you have a new
book which you have there which i have
not yet read but i will you're also the
author of the uh in addition to
introduction to cosmology now on its
second edition your author of
foundations of astrophysics and your new
book is called interstellar and
intergalactic medium published by
cambridge university press a renowned
institution as well so barbara when i
have authors on my podcast the very
first thing i do
is i ask them you know they say don't
judge a book by its cover barbara but uh
but what else are you going to judge it
on i mean besides your reputation if
you've written a book before um so i
want to ask you what is the impetus for
the new cover what was the impetus for
the old covers and by the way this is
like the square root of the number of
copies i have i've got many many more
elsewhere um
so what was the intro what was the um
the inspiration for the graphics and the
cover of both editions
well the first edition of introduction
to cosmology
was the very first book that i wrote
putting to one side my phd dissertation
which as you know is kind of a quasi
book
but
um i knew nothing about nothing
fortunately
uh pearson the publisher of the book
had a great deal of experience and found
this really great uh cover illustrator
who knew a bit about science and so on
the first edition
you hold up the picture you see it's
actually a representation of the
expansion of the universe the big egg is
down near the bottom
so
you start with the big bang every
universe starts to expand some universes
then crunch down again in the big crunch
some of them keep expanding at a
constant rate and you know the one that
flares out that's an accelerating
universe
so it's
very graphically interesting and i
believe the cover for the first edition
actually won some point kind of book
design award
so really got lucky with the first
edition and that the books
yeah the the book did win the chambliss
astronomical writing award among many
other um uh honors and accolades
well-deserved tell us about the second
edition's cover
well the second edition
it has to look enough like the first
edition that people recognize it so
still has the title on top author's name
on bottom
the black background but this time we
wanted a punch of color
so
the color image is actually a simulation
of the universe i forget schwann one of
the illustrious simulations i think it's
all in the back cover of yours properly
credited yes but
this was number one to look pretty nice
splash of color and secondly to
emphasize one of
the advances
of the second edition it has more about
structure formation more about the
formation of clusters of galaxies in the
filaments of the cosmic web as you see
nicely and that's
a nice brightly colored illustration on
front
yes and i mentioned just before we
started recording that i am in the
office uh once occupied by the late
great uh jeffrey burbidge and his uh his
wife margaret was a good friend also
unfortunately no longer with us one of
the things i inherited when i became uh
the office holder is i inherited some of
uh margaret's plates used from sarah
colollo
and i treasure these so much
and i wanted to kind of take us back to
uh something that's not covered in
introduction to cosmology and those are
alternative cosmological models um you
uh you which i'm not expecting that you
should teach but i want to get your
perspective on those kinds of models
obviously margaret was one of the most
eminent astronomers of all time and she
was kind of tenuously affiliated with
the quasi-steady state models um but
what was your take why why do people
like past guests on my podcast giant
narlikar a student of fred hoyles why do
you think it's still so
resilient these these kind of
alternatives to cosmo
the big bang model uh and certainly
inflation why are they still so
resilient in your opinion
well
in my opinion
for what it's worth um someone is
probably historical
i like pointing out
to my students
that as recently as the year 1963
malcolm longhair another very eminent
cosmologist was a graduate student and
heard from his advisor
a sentence that he never forgot in 1963
he was told there are only two and a
half facts in cosmology
two and a half packs
and this is less than 60 years ago right
so in 1963 oh
uh adopting a steady states or
quasi-steady-state
model for the universe that was entirely
in an agreement with the two and a half
facts that known
the two and a half facts by the way
where the night sky is dark the
so-called olbers paradox which of course
has been known for a long time
hack number two galaxies show a red
shift proportional to their distance
and the half a fact was in the early
1960s
radio surveys of the universe had gone
far enough out in space far enough back
in time
so that people were starting to believe
that oh yeah you know the population of
galaxies has changed significantly with
time
in the past there were a lot more active
galaxies radio galaxies
quasars than there are now so now kind
of hinting that things were different in
the past than they are now
and the discovery of the cosmic
microwave background
the mid-1960s by penzias and wilson was
really what tipped people towards the
hot big bang model
the idea that
a finite but fairly long time in the
past the universe was very much denser
and hotter than it is now that has been
the background radiation has been
cooling off as the universe expands
yeah of course that is a big a big uh
topic of research that i study but um i
think it's still interesting that even
afterwards even after the discovery of
the microwave background even after the
nobel prize was awarded to uh penzias
and wilson there were still kind of some
holdouts and and even uh there was
attempts to kind of make the
interstellar medium or the intergalactic
medium do the heavy lifting of
thermalizing starlight energy
and uh and and what was it like uh you
know you were around princeton um you
know after that period but uh what was
it like in that period in the aftermath
of kind of the princeton team getting
scooped by bob dickey getting scooped by
pension wilson and my advisor's advisor
david wilkinson do you recall that
emilia and when you were a graduate
student at princeton and what was uh
what was your reaction when you you know
kind of when during the kind of
solidification of what we now in your
book call the benchmark model
well it's interesting as a graduate
student you know i was at princeton and
now had jim t bowles as one of my
professors
so
um really tied into the kind of the
theoretical princetonian side
but also
the
one observational project i did as a
graduate student i went out to to bell
labs and
actually worked with tony stark
tony stark this with the radio stronger
tony stark iron man and observed
millimeter emission from carbon
carbon monoxide in the andromeda galaxy
however when i was there
bob wilson of penzius and wilson was
still working there and of course my
eyes went like saucers you have to
understand i was a very naive graduate
student so
really in awe of everything that was
going on i thought oh wow nobel prize
winner he's probably you know seven feet
tall and wears a oral wreath every day
and then i met him and you know
this average size guy at the time was
balding a little on top and when i
remember most clearly he came to the
group lunch meeting carrying his lunch
in a little brown paper bag
and
then i i found that very cheering you
know
if you're a nobel prize winner you're
not this awe-inspiring person in always
in most ways you're just a person right
yeah they uh they put their pants on one
leg at a time and
like the rest of us anyway you know bob
wilson was such a nice guy and so
encouraging that no
i i didn't resent him for having you
know scooped
the group at princeton in the physics
department there
and um i want to talk about we were as
we say world line uh in astronomy and
research so um what was your thesis on
in in princeton and where did you go
after that and how did you end up at osu
as a buckeye
okay
um
my thesis
at
princeton was with jim gunn tamil prize
winner and it was on galaxy formation in
universe dominated with cold dark matter
so at the time cold dark matter kind of
a new idea and people realized that
oh yeah
the
universe early on will be
lumpy not entirely homogeneous
and the dead slumps will collapse and
what my piece is mostly focused on is as
they collapse they feel
a torque due to tides from neighboring
collapsing objects so they get spun up
so basically my thesis was
is the spin up
rates
of these collapsing objects
comparable to
the observed spin of galaxies
basic answer was you know sort of if you
wave your hands around a lot that the
the total amount of angular momentum was
correct
however the distribution of angular
momentum
was it's you know what the simplest
theory predicted you had to have
transfer of angular momentum i think it
was from the outer regions the inner
regions or vice versa
it's been a long time since my
dissertation
but
that was an interesting experience
because jim gunn as you know both this
amazing theorist and this amazing
observer
and while i was working on my
dissertation
he was observing a lot at palomar yes
california opposite coast from new
jersey
and so
he was observing you know distant
galaxies he needed dark time so i called
him my where advisor is in werewolf
because i only saw him when the moon was
full
during new moon he was over out in
california observing more than 100 inch
hit elevar
so
he would come back hit full moon and
look at what i had done he said yeah
that's interesting but now this means
that you should probably do x and if x
turns out to be y then you can go on to
z and i said oh wow gosh
i haven't gone to that
and so i would work busily away at his
suggestions and then i would come to the
end of his suggestions and i might have
no idea what to do next
so
i would fall into this deep depression
oh
which of course would be lifted
whenever jim got returned from
california
so
it was kind of this extreme mood swing
with a period of
one synthetic month
i mean all graduate students i know go
to these ups and downs but mine was just
totally
correlated with the phases of the moon
anyway having jim gunn as your thesis
advisor it's a wonderful thing because
you get the world's best letters of
recommendation
and once i got my phd i went to
the harvard smithsonian center for
astrophysics
in cambridge
i was on the smithsonian side
really doesn't matter which side you're
on harvard or smithsonian
it's all the same they're all tossed
into the same bin
the only difference is if you're
a harvard
postdoc you get to wear the harvard halo
that's right
well when i was there i started doing
some
different things always a good thing to
do when you're a postdoc
i worked with bill press talking about
late time phase transitions
which is
a kind of a
slightly wonky way of
making large scale structures
which as it turns out didn't work very
well at making large-scale structures
but it was a very interesting
mathematical problem
anyway three years at the harvard
smithsonian center for astrophysics then
i got another postdoc at the canadian
institute for theoretical astrophysics
multitude canadian duster physique
theoretique
they're obliged to be bilingual there
but of course everybody calls it ceta
from its acronym
that was an interesting place to be
because
basically it was a large number of
post-docs
and a few professors
so
i think it's been called the inmates
running the asylum but
when you put a lot of postdocs together
in one place and you know they don't
have teaching duties
it does become very intellectually
lively
so two years there you know canada
wanted to toss me out so i realized at
that point in my career wow if wants to
toss you out that's uh that's saying
something you know i call them the 51st
state never 29.99
i applied for jobs everywhere
did some interviews and it turns out of
the places i interviewed i kind of liked
ohio state's the best and as it turns
out they made me a job offer
so
basic reason why i'm at the ohio state
university is they offered me a job
it's a job at a place that i thought was
uh going places
yeah
they did a lot of faculty hiring at
about the same time i was hired
which made a nice strong cohort of
course it now means
the group of people that was hired in
the 1990s is kind of the pathing passing
through the python
starting to approach retirement age over
the next decade so there's going to be a
lot of
turnover soon
yes and you know when i think about ohio
first of all i i i do recognize that
ohio state is the second best university
in ohio after my alma mater case western
reserve ghost spartans i can't i can't
uh deny doing that at least once but um
but i learned a tremendous amount there
this book wasn't around but uh when i
was a student i actually never took a
cosmology class
and when i actually took a cosmology
class they're serious
i never took a cosmology classes in
undergraduates me neither
was a graduate course
you know cosmology and galaxies and so a
lot of stuff thrown together so
and osmo portion of that course was
taught by rich scott one of the world's
great eccentrics
yes yes uh yeah uh and that's proof
of astronomers saying somebody's a three
sigma eccentric that's really saying
something
i think of you as as uh as normal and in
every in the best possible sense of the
word but of course you know every every
cosmologist has to be somewhat quirky at
least to get into this field which is
you know as you say requires us to stay
up late and uh and uh wake up uh wake up
at the crack of of or go to bed at the
crack of of dawn
um
when we whenever i teach this wonderful
book
i'm always you know kind of uh torn do i
teach that there are other
possible values for the curvature of the
universe in other words there are three
different possibilities and spatial
curvature and you go through this in in
tender detail uh ranging from flat to uh
positively curved like a sphere
negatively curved like a pringles chip
but um but we now know barbara don't we
now know that the universe is flat with
a
with a with a precision of less than
half a percent so why teach the
controversy why don't we just keep it
you know just teach only the flat
universe that's the dilemma i go through
every year of course i teach everything
in your book verbatim but uh but tell me
should i struggle with this should i
feel guilty about about teaching them
things that we know aren't aren't
correct
on the one hand
if you're doing all the mathematics and
writing things down
yes go ahead and assume the universe is
flat
it's flat to within a half a percent and
it makes the math
so much easier
on the other hand no
in ancient egypt people assumed the
earth was flat because the part of it
they could see
the region
mainly around egypt it's pretty gosh
darn flat
so we can only see a finite portion of
the universe
because there's been a finite time
collapse the big bang
so it's possible that's the portion of
the universe that we can see with our
telescopes
is
close to flat but
if you could look on much larger scales
it could be positively or negatively
curved
so
you can approach this from a practical
viewpoint
yeah we're only interested in what we
can see it's so close to flat then we
might as well
might as well say that it's perfectly
flat flatter than kansas flatter than a
pancake in kansas flat flat flat
from a broader you might say a more
philosophical viewpoint you know the
idea that it could be positively curved
on very large scales and have a finite
volume
i think is
appealing to a lot of people
including me yeah i don't know about you
but infinity gives me the heebie-jeebies
explain explain what that means the
heebie-jeebies you've never had the
heebie-jeebies i do but i want to
explain why does the infinite flatness
of the universe of the infinitesimal
curvature give you those prescriptive
heebie-jeebies
well well infinity in general if you're
not a mathematician
is hard to grasp
and there's the idea of
the universe is expanding
homogeneously and isotropically on all
scales now
if it is
infinitely large
then some finite time in the past yeah
it
was
any two points were very much closer to
each other in the past than they are now
but you know infinity divided by a large
number
as long as it's finite is still infinity
so
uh gulp yeah
uh so if the universe is
finite but very very very very very very
very big
then
you divide it by a large number and you
get a small number
i'm not being very coherent but that's
what tends to happen to me when i start
talking about infinity
and i always point out that we have no
examples of anything infinite in the
physical world uh we have notions of
infinity that uh that a human brain can
contemplate but even a computer like the
simulations on the on the cover of the
second edition they have to make
approximations as to what infinity is we
have no example kind of like zeno's
paradox whenever i talk about it you
know you can't get there from here
because you have to go halfway and then
halfway to their quarter way eighth way
etc so you never get to exactly where
you're going according to xeno but in
infinity imagine something infinitely
dense infinitely hot how does it
transition how does it gracefully taper
from something infinite to something
less than infinite that's not infinite
so my kids always say i love you
infinity and i say you should say
infinity squared infinity cubed infinity
anyway it doesn't matter but half of
infinity is still happening one of my
kids is a wise wise butt and he says you
know i love you half of infinity but
you're right it is kind of paradoxical
and it seems that computers can't grasp
infinity only human beings can and yet
we toss it around like singularities
infinite density in a black hole or at
the big bang we just kind of play around
with it willy-nilly and it gives me the
heebie-jeebies to be so willy-nilly
yes i think you've summed it up
perfectly
one of my footwork's undergraduate
professors i was an undergraduate at
northwestern university
we'd say okay we take these two charged
particles and we move them so they're
infinitely far apart let me stop to to
explain that's not real infinity that's
physicist exactly
and you described physicist infinity as
any distance so large that if you
doubled it it would not make a
measurable dis difference
do anything that you could measure for
that system right
exactly so yeah we'll say the inverse is
perfectly flat
or has an infinitely large radius of
curvature that really means
the radius of curvature is so big we
can't measure it yes
and we just make these uh approximations
as if we can uh you know really
comprehend what we're saying and then we
tell the computer just divide by the
largest number that you have but it
doesn't matter that's uh that's pitiful
and indifferent to
how big it is but that kind of brings up
one of the questions that i have and you
talk about in the end of the book and
maybe this dovetails into our initial
discussion of alternative cosmologies
and that's about inflation so you know
that there are many different um uh you
know sorts of of of concepts for how the
universe could have began that don't
involve inflation and inflation is kind
of the third rail and some circles of
politics even though it does so many
things spectacularly well there are
people like nobel laureate sir roger
penrose or paul steinhardt neil turock
and aegis and others who claim well not
so fast maybe there are other models of
how cosmogenesis took place i've always
been curious of course you present
in the standard context in a very
delightful way which i'm reproducing and
i'm actually distilling into a separate
video that i reference you in uh kind of
a crash course in inflation you know
derived from my my teaching of your book
but um what do you make of these
alternatives to cosmogenesis is that
outside the scope of what cosmology is
to you
um
cosmogenesis
wow that's a big word
i don't think i've ever said the word
cosmogenesis before
because
well
because you've read my book so many
times you realize that it starts out
here and now
and then goes back in time
i like to say that cosmo just sort of
like playing chicken with each other you
know oh yeah i do big bang
nucleosynthesis i talk about what the
universe was like when it was only three
minutes old yeah
basically i talked about bariogenesis i
know what the universe was like when it
was one second old and so
everybody says oh i can go back further
in time than you
no
i told you i i mean that observational
astronomy
at millimeter wavelengths so
they do tend to obsess about what we can
see what we can measure and from
measurements and observations what can
we deduce about what the early universe
is like
and i think the section in my textbook
about inflation
sort of takes that viewpoint we look at
the universe today
it is
as we can see very close to flats or
euclidean
you extrapolate it back in time
and you are going to say oh gosh you
know before dark energy
or the cosmological constant or whatever
you want to call it over
huh
the the density parameter omega
measuring the difference
of the curvature from perfect flatness
oh gosh the universe has become less
flat with time yeah as it goes on
therefore if it's so close to flat today
at the time of big bad nuclear synthesis
for instance it must have been
incredibly impossibly close to flat so
how do you explain
extrapolating back to
no big bang nuclear synthesis three
minutes all the universe we understood
pretty well
how could we explain so
lickety-blink
blank blank so very close to flat
and the general concept of inflation
you know there was this period when the
universe was temporarily undergoing
accelerating
expansion
the general concept is very good
explaining why the universe is flat
and also by inflating
fluctuations on the quantum scale
explains why it's not perfectly flat
that it explains why the density is
perfectly uniform
so it's a good example of killing two
birds with one stone however
there are as you mentioned other ideas
about cosmogenesis
that could explain it so
the question
no in in my opinion
everything i'm saying that was my
opinion
you're not speaking on behalf of big
cosmology
yeah i'm in their pocket they just pay
me huge sums of my
parents of the party line
so
you have two
hypotheses they both explain what you
can see about it as well so you need
some sort of test between them
you know like the famous 1919 solar
eclipse
newton
newtonian physics predicts one value for
gravitational lensing
einstein's newfangled theory of general
relativity predicts a different value
for gravitationalizing you go out and
you measure things
unless you support one theory rather
than the other
and when you look at the history of of
cosmology of course we live in a
different age where
there's things like social media and
you're not
you're so productive because you're not
very often on social media although i
did contact you uh via a social media um
but um but i'm always thinking about
these alternative models in the context
of imagining a young
james clerk maxwell and he's toiling
away and he's coming up with these
beautiful field theories he's unifying
electricity and magnetism
and his equations are of course flawless
and still hold to this day in various
guises but then he has to have this
mechanical interpretation
how does the electromagnetic wave wave
and how does it propagate what through
what does it propagate and so he
constitutes it constitutes this kind of
mechanistic gear and pulley and sort of
vortice system and i can imagine
facebook back then barbara you know like
you know top physicist claims that you
know micro gears are responsible for you
know maybe they would have believed it
maybe that would have been better but um
certainly it could have nowadays would
have uh if twitter existed would have
cast a lot of doubt on it i want to ask
you when you look at you know novel
ideas now um versus kind of this you
know big cosmology we joke about um do
you think that social media or you know
just the rapid rise the internet
channels like this one youtube channel
do you think that that's a good thing is
it is it maybe squelching
nascent theories before they have a
chance to be tested or properly fleshed
out as you know as you talk about in the
book you know einstein had ideas back in
1914
about gr but a lot of those were
incorrect numerically and so forth and
it took until the you know 1919 eclipse
until they were verified so to speak um
i don't ask you do you think that like
the presence of social media and instant
gratification that we need to like get
your position right now is that [ __ ]
squashing
new potentially generative ideas in
cosmology or is it you know not really a
big deal
well
chartered so that is i don't know
as you mentioned i'm not a big part of
the twitter sphere
and yes you could argue both ways
you have social media
you have this new outlet so you don't
have to
become a member of an academy or
submit to one of the established
journals on the other hand
you just send off a random tweet and
it's really
just goes
tweeting past like a little bird
so
i suppose you could say it's too early
to tell
how about that for a waffle statement
so recently i've had on a lot of um
a lot of uh astrophysicist friends of
ours seth shawstak i had jill tarter on
earlier
actually late last year
and there's a lot of resurgence and
interest into
whether or not extraterrestrial
intelligence exists and as you know on
august 15 1977
at the ohio state university's big ear
radio telescope there was detected
the wow signal i want to ask you what uh
do you
do you think that there are
extraterrestrial intelligence
civilizations out in the universe do you
think that there aren't do you think
there's life let me start with that do
you think there's life elsewhere in the
cosmos barbara
yes
did i say that confidently because who
can disprove it
hundreds of billions of stars in our
galaxy
maybe a trillion galaxies within that
finite portion of the universe
that we can see
yeah would be astonishing if there
weren't
another planet out there with life
however you know if there exists for
instance so a single planet covered with
slime mold in the andromeda galaxy two
and a half billion light years away
that's
how would that affect yeah
how would you feel about that
emotionally would you say
hooray we're not alone in the universe
there exists a slime mold billions of
light years away
when you say yeah okay we live in a
universe with lots of unusual stuff so
with so many planets around so many
stars out there you're gonna find
a lot of stuff or you would find a lot
of stuff if you could examine and be
planted in the galaxy
in detail in every planet and every
other galaxy
and when we look out in the universe i
also feel that you're right um you know
people say oh it'll be a magnificent day
you know we discover life on you know
some planet proxima century b or
something like that and it's i say yeah
it depends as you say on what kind of
life it is if it's a slime mold and it
produces some kind of aerobic you know
excrement like like our uh
bacteriological four ancestors did many
many um billions of years ago perhaps in
the great oxidation event um would we
feel a kinship towards them because of
their existence i don't think so because
i think you know you can go right up
north to lake erie and scoop a cup of
water and there'll be some kind of you
know you know life that's living there
even in extremophilic conditions like
chilled tartar is popularized so i don't
and i don't think people say wow you
know we have this kinship with with the
with the universe because of this
existence of single-celled organisms so
i think it might be short-lived i think
people would say wow unless it is like
communicating and then and then you have
to wonder you know are they
technological what can they teach us do
they want to eat us
but anyway
i i think uh i think it's fascinating to
discuss
these topics but and it's great to get
your opinion and for some reason it's in
the news a lot so i couldn't resist uh
you know i'm pinging you about that but
now um because we're reaching the end
and now i'm going to have to go and
teach
a graduate class but now i don't use
this book for that
i want to first point out that i think
and and tell me if i'm wrong barbara
that this book um is such a wonderful
book and the fact that you are a woman
and that you wrote it i think is
important because
i don't know of any other books that we
use in curricula for physics majors that
are written by women that's in the
standard you know this is this is used
by millions of you know people or has
been used by hundreds of thousands
do you know of any other book written
say that again
tens of thousands well the multiverse is
true there could be millions um it's
such a wonderful book it doesn't matter
you know to be but but do you know of
any other you know books that have uh of
such a scholarship that are written as
and used as textbooks so wildly widely
as your book is
well let me see dive down the stack of
textbooks here
my current book the one that i'm working
on now
is on stellar structure with mark
fincino
and let's see oh introduction to stellar
structure and evolution
excellent book female author
um
don't worry i'm coming back it's okay
maybe your cat can come back up and not
fill in introduction to stellar
astrophysics erica bowman v tents
one of the standard works in the field
so
on the one hand
astronomy
does have this history of female
astronomers
recently a small minority of astronomers
but they've always been there
and
well
on the one hand i think that having
female textbook writers and female
observers and female theorists females
permeating
every form of astronomy is a good thing
and
well i don't know
if somebody has introduction to
cosmology
assigned to them in the course
and they find out it's written by
somebody named barbara
and they know enough about western
naming
and then tends to realize that barbara
is a woman's name it's their mother's
name in my case
ah
excellent name
um
well
it's not going to be a big thing but
many many small things yeah
big things yeah i mean you see san diego
you may not know but it was the home of
maria geppert mayor who was the uh first
american uh woman to win a nobel prize
and she was the last female winner of
the nobel prize until uh three years ago
when donna strickland won and now andre
i guess is one so it's it's the number
women have doubled but you know we'd
have to give away you know three nobel
prizes to women every year for the next
hundred years to kind of reach uh par
parity between men and women but i do
think it's significant in one sense that
um you know if you if you do get exposed
and it's only yes maybe you will not
notice it until it's you know until it's
assigned to you or whatever but you know
but i think students do notice it and i
have about luckily and happily i have
about half of my students that take the
class cosmology class are are women and
and i just love it and half of my
graduate students have been women
and we have this rich tradition with
with uc san diego with maria geppermair
and you know she was denied a position
for many years because she was a woman
and we were the first institution
argonne didn't offer her one uh johns
hopkins didn't offer her one we of
course had sally ride was my late great
colleague in the physics department
first american woman in space
and we had vera rubin studied with uh
jeff and margaret burbidge here and she
learned how to do a lot of the
spectroscopic work that she later used
to to derive rotation curves from
margaret and she credits margaret she
credited margaret
so yes and we've had many many women
authors on the podcast from katy freeze
sarah seeger uh we have sarah
rugg hummer coming on and uh and i think
it's i think it's it's wonderful and i
think astronomy in particular does a
much better job than physics as a whole
and and i think you know i'm hoping the
trend will kind of percolate over to
physics as well because i think it's it
is necessary for people to see not that
they have to be exactly like me or you
for me to learn from them but it's good
to see that there is a trend at least in
the positive direction um as as as many
because many of the women that i've had
on are popular science authors i don't
think any of them have they've all
written books janet levin i've had her
on many times uh sarah seeger like
they're all written popular so called
popular science books which are
wonderful and i love them but it's great
to see a textbook too so anyway i just
wanted to throw that in there and um and
now if you're willing
i'm going to read the lowest ranked
review on amazon of your no i'm not
going to do that sometimes i have done
that i play a game i call it high and
low but with a popular author i say do
you want to read the high five star
review with the most helpful votes on
amazon and then you have to read the one
star review and reply to it but they
have to be uh verified in other words
you can't just like
like many people do leave me a one-star
review but they never read my book
anyway um i wanna i wanna thank you and
i wanna see if we can go into the
impossible and ants if you can ask uh
answer one of my questions that i ask
all of my guests or many of my guests
that i'm honored to have on my podcast
and that has to do with um the deep
future of the universe
and it relates to arthur c clarke which
is the namesake of the center that i
co-direct here at university of
california san diego
and uh in 2001 a space odyssey you may
recall if you've seen the movie barbara
have you seen it
yes so there are these monoliths and
they're kind of these ominous maybe time
capsules maybe machines that convey some
sort of information but they're meant to
be discovered when human beings have the
capacity to uh to unearth what's inside
of them and to really appreciate it i
want to ask you barbara
as i asked andrewian who actually did
this um the widow of carl sagan um i
want to ask you if you had a billion
year lasting time capsule
and you guaranteed to last for for that
period of time what would you put in it
or on it or you know about it
so that you could convey some sort of
knowledge or teaching or wisdom or
anything that you feel valuable that
signifies the human condition and what
we've achieved as a species
so
one billion years
okay anything i put inside will last for
a billion years if i decided to send the
six pack of beer the future a billion
years
it will not go stale inside this magical
time capsule
you do your joke but beer of course is
was a major step forward in human
civilization
the problem of course is that a billion
years is so long compared to
human history
a trifling you know five or six thousand
years since we invented writing
and
very long compared to
time
the time that homo sapiens has been
around
or even compared to the time that
primates have been around so
you'd have to say well a billion years
in the future anybody who's going to
open up this magic time capsule is going
to be somebody
quite different from me
yeah and i can't assume that for
instance ethanol is going to give them a
bond so let's
um
let's skip the beer
and drink it all ourselves
in the future
i'm inclined to be a little humorous
here and say hey well let's put in
copies of all of my textbooks there's
nothing wrong with that no
let them know what conditions were like
in this patch of the universe a billion
years earlier so they
extrapolate forward get some interesting
inside into
cosmological evolution
but
joking aside i keep going back to you
know
books maybe movies
this reminds me in fact of
an essay question
i post on one of my exams for your basic
astro 101 course
we've been talking in class you know
about the voyager golden record
and the various sound clips that carl
sagan decided to
say this is our culture
yes and the question i asked was you
know
okay you're sending another probe into
space this time we're going to send out
so some sort of
audio visual
so not just sounds but sounds and images
and you can send
let's say
five hours in total
what movies would you pick
documentary
comedy tragedy
uh something that shows human beings in
a good light something highly idealized
something a little bit darker you just
want to show them what humans are like
warts and all
the most interesting thing about
that question was
every student came up with a different
answer
so
i think the
answer would have to be
just flinging a whole bunch of stuff
high culture low culture
let's give them people
throwing pies in a slapstick comedy
let's give them king lear
and just show them
not only what humans knew intellectually
sure let's give them cosmos neil
degrasse tyson and cosmos carol sagan so
you have two different views of the
cosmos
but let's uh just give them this huge
cross section
this is what the species was like at
this particular time on this planet
and oh by the way a billion years from
now good luck i hope that you two laugh
and cry
i hope you have a usb stick drive reader
on your spaceship uh barbara that is so
beautiful and so thoughtful and it does
remind me i had andrew and ahn who is
the widow of carl sagan and they had met
just a week or two and i'll put a link
to that in the video description above
but
she had met carl you know or fallen in
love with him just a few weeks before
hand and and he asked her to record her
brain waves and they put it on the
voyager golden disc and so she's
ruminating on her love
for this wonderful man carl sagan
whose daughter has also been on the
podcast sasha sagan and um it's just so
beautiful because when i asked her i
said what would you put on it and uh
what would you put on such a
hypothetical time count she said i
already have done that you know with the
voyager golden did
she's a wonderful woman she actually
gave me a religious answer which is kind
of funny from a secular person such as
herself but barbara i really i just want
to thank you so much um
your your book is is reads like a
page-turning novel i i i read it you
know i take it to the beach here in san
diego it's it's it's such a service to
young people because it's accessible it
doesn't it it presents it at a high
level it gives them a taste of what life
will be like if they choose to go to
graduate school not all do so you have
enough kind of red meat or red tofu if
you're a vegan you know that will allow
you to to really flame the incipient
fans of of curiosity and my motto on
this channel is abc always be curious
and barbara i just want to thank you so
much you you and i just met this first
time we've ever spoken i hope we can
meet in person someday maybe they are
maybe here and um and again i just want
to thank you for your graciousness your
good humor and and your co and your
written work and i do want a copy of
that new book so i can read it and even
though i don't do anything in stellar
physics whatsoever i will uh assume it's
going to be as much of a page turner as
this one so barbara thank you so much
for going into the impossible for
everything you've done for the
multiverse
now thank you for
talking with me and i hope we do meet in
person preferably in san diego
yeah maybe in january
january columbus ohio versus january in
la jolla it's up to you bubba anytime
okay thank you so much barbara
you're welcome
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
so
[Music]
you